the Joe Rogan experience I just in my
car driving all this in a Woody Allen do
stand-up in the 1960s yeah you could
tell he was a [ __ ] pervert even back
then yeah well you know there was a line
there was a line and loved it
there was a line in love and death over
love and death yes and Diane Keaton goes
to this high priest and she steps on his
beard and it's very funny scene and he
says the most beautiful thing in the
world is a 12 year old girl blonde hair
preferably twins right and this is all
this perverted things yeah this this has
happened 20 years B 25 years before he
got accused of anything yeah you know
but it was just interesting here no cuz
he did a couple he did it even in
Manhattan with Hemingway was a little
bit a little bit twisted you know I
don't remember Manhattan very much well
he falls in love and she falls in love
with him she's like supposed to be 16
and he's Jesus Christ yeah well it's not
something that people tend to do they
try to normalize whatever [ __ ] up
provision half and they put it in the
art like that was one of the things that
they were accusing louis c.k of with
this movie that he released right before
it came out that he was jerking off in
front of a bunch of it though they had
this movie and part of the movie was
just talking about how everyone's a
pervert we're all perverts I'll tell you
something off the air oh can we get off
remind me to tell you I don't want to
sit down with Dom our era that's your
new show off the air with Dahmer era all
I do is burn people and lose any context
at everybody is this thing on it's not I
gotta go in there actually the night
that he went or the the Day Afternoon
when I went onstage I got I said I'm so
excited I got a part in a Louis CK's new
TV show should shoot in about 10 15
years and I took him a beat and then
they got it
I think he'll be back in a year well you
know what Joey has that advantage of he
was the one that created the idea of
selling your own thing right yes so he
can do that he doesn't need a producer
for that that's true that's true
um you'd have him on this show right I
would 100% oh come on
yeah I think he's a different person
than when he did those things I think
what those things that he did jerking
off in front of a bunch of people was
terrible and I think he probably had an
idea in his head of what those things
were and of who he was and who he would
be and I think a lot of your self
definitions a lot of times are based on
this very limited idea of who you are
very limited idea of who you're going to
be and he's like wallowing in his own
weirdness and just wants a jerk off in
front of someone you know it's out of
all the offenses of things you could do
to someone it's one of the least
egregious because he's not raping he's
not as he didn't lock the door he's not
yeah he didn't lock the door he's not
doing anything awful to someone he's
just doing something weird in front of
them I think it's beautiful
do you know I don't think it's beautiful
there's a lot of things that I think of
you to think it's a plike it's
definitely a pike well it's it's human
like then I batted it out of the air
because an ape doesn't really care if
you're jerking oh if you're watching
when he's jerking he could be jerking
over the banana in one hand banana in
the other get it
Hey yeah I know all the things that he
did and I think that his apology but
pretty was what's a way to look at it
I think was honest I think it sort of
explained how his mind worked and why he
did it in the first place it's not it's
obviously not something he's proud of
it's obviously something he's disgusted
by himself and you can't here's the
thing you jerk off in front of someone
10 years ago how do you fix that you
don't do it again and he hasn't done it
again here's the thing no one's saying
he's done anything in a long time like
all the accusations were like I want to
say they were from there from years ago
right what do you do like how do you fix
that
like sit say you did jerk off in front
of a few people dumb like you know like
I don't know why came in front of a
blind lady is that is that still count
it depends on how good her hearing is oh
here she's here
yeah you're right she's like what are
you doing over there
and she has to guess it's all [ __ ]
guesswork woody how do you fix that like
what does a guy do to fix that I mean I
think out of all the people like how the
[ __ ] would you rehabilitate Harvey
Weinstein how do you let Harvey
Weinstein around a woman again how do
you how do you leave Harvey Weinstein in
a hotel room with a woman who comes in
for a meeting or Cosby was worst he's
the worst
he's the word I don't think you can
really belted him how what do you do how
do you how do you how do you fix that
the only way Cosby gets rehabilitated I
mean not really rehabilitated but the
only way he gets reintroduced into
society is if everyone believes those
girls are lying and doesn't ever happen
it's impossible because everybody heard
those stories a long time ago when I did
Star Search in like 83 and he was the
guest host and we were hearing [ __ ]
about him on the set then really women
Eisen and stuff yeah I mean Chris might
not as his extremist druggie drug in
them run raping them but like if you're
a guy like louis c.k how do you what do
you do like what woody what could he
have done before the story came out that
he's doing that to girls what what could
he have done to to make amends I mean
what could he have done he said sorry to
some of the people I don't know why you
looking at me like that I don't I'm just
trying to think I'm just trying I'm
you're my friend I'm looking at you
right there I'm just thinking like what
would one do I mean it seems like let's
I mean I'm not exonerating him right but
it seems like all these years since then
he hasn't done it again right so if he
hasn't done it again he must understand
that there's something wrong with that
yeah some weird compulsion and it had to
be a power thing because if anybody
could get a hooker and do that you know
well here's the thing he's probably
doing that too yeah I mean if he liked
jerking off in front of people he might
just like jerking off in front of all
kinds of people he might have jerked off
in front hoof to I don't know but we
know that he did it in front of women
that really didn't want it yes that's
what I thought it might be part of the
kinkiness so yeah but there's some
stories of him doing it in front of
women they thought it was hilarious
he didn't find some female comics and
they thought it was hilarious
how do you stay hard when they're
laughing you gotta be a real animal it's
better than better man than me Dom but I
did a lot I don't know what you think of
this line but I what do you and I see
that mentioned on stage and these women
started bowing I said why are you bowing
they said because of what he did and the
daughter and all this I said look I
don't know I said by the one thing you
gotta admit he really must love her
because it's not like she's hot you know
I know but that got a laugh
[Applause]